how's it going everybody welcome to
today's ask a career coach my name is
Martin McGovern and I'm a career adviser
here at Udacity we're gonna give it just
a couple of minutes for some folks to
join us and then we'll be diving into
our initial topic of today which will be
about LinkedIn and then diving into all
of the questions that you have on your
mind in regards to your career how to
find work how to network how to
interview how to build your online
presence and so on so if you have
questions we have Rui in the chat she'll
be passing along those questions right
to me so please send your questions into
the chat of this video and we'll get
into them throughout the next hour thank
you again for joining us I'm really
excited to chat with you today see what
questions come up and see how we can
help you not only figure out how to do
the job search in the best way possible
but also lay on that job that you really
really hope to get in the future now as
you're joining us we're gonna wait just
a few minutes for folks to join the call
we've got a good number of you already
sitting and waiting and watching along
but I just wanna give a few more minutes
for people to join since this is on
YouTube live while we're waiting give a
shout of where you are in the world we
usually get people from all over the
globe on these calls so it's really
interesting and exciting to see what
time it is by you what the weather is
you know what yesterday we had the polar
vortex here in Chicago so it was I think
negative 40 windchill maybe even more
than that I went outside earlier today
and literally had icicles form on my
eyelashes so it's kind of crazy cold out
here
curious how it is by you where you are
give a shout in the comments and start
adding in those questions those career
questions that are on your mind and
we'll start collecting them right away
all right I'm just going to call out
some of the locations Oh
yesterday it was colder in Chicago than
it was on the surface of parts of Mars
kind of a crazy thing to think about
colder than the Arctic colder than
anything that is true incredible joy
Chicago is actually Windy City after all
we actually got that nickname in regards
to our politicians being windbags
but the the name really sticks because
of how windy it is out here especially
over by the lake where I am all right
it's 18 degrees Celsius in India thank
you so much for joining us we've got
Egypt thank you for joining us thank you
for the invite to join you in Egypt I
wish it is uh it is brisk out there
Stockholm Sweden
very cool Bolivia thank you for joining
us Gaby and Anna Brazil India Munich
Germany it is 9:00 p.m.
thank you for staying up late and
joining us on tonight's call today's
call for him meeting tonight for you to
am in India serious props to India right
now Wow
2 a.m. I'm so proud of y'all New York
1:30 in the morning in India Vancouver
Saudi Arabia Guadalajara
India India Cairo thank you for
submitting your first question Haiti so
please everyone if you have questions
please start sharing them in the chat
we'll be collecting them and getting to
them shortly 1 degrees Celsius in Munich
it's cold everywhere Hong Kong awesome
says hello hello awesome Columbia
Rayleigh North Carolina Chicago
hey hey J I hope you're keeping warm
over there in Chicago
Virginia Ecuador Indonesia 3 a.m. Wow
serious props for staying up late with
us or getting up early whatever you did
it's been raining for two days in
Pakistan hope you're staying dry
San Francisco negative 2 in Stockholm
wow we got some great folks in the chat
today thank you so much for joining us
we're about 5 minutes in so I'm gonna
get rolling with things and get the
conversation started this is a perfect
time for you to start thinking about
what questions you have on your mind and
anything that you're thinking about even
if it's not related to our main topic
today we will get into it I know we
typically don't get to all the questions
in every session so if you ask the
question in a previous week and we
didn't get to it or you'd like more
explanation please drop it in the
comments and we'll try and get to it
today again my name is Martin McGovern
and I'm a career advisor here at Udacity
my background is primarily in marketing
branding and career development so I
don't have as in depth of knowledge
around the hyper technical aspects of
your job search so if you're a
programmer if you're doing whiteboarding
I know generally how to approach some of
those things but for the most part my
expertise lies in how to communicate how
to network how to interview how to sell
yourself how to present yourself online
and so on in order to get the job that
you want so we can ask questions are on
strategy around marketing around
networking around all those different
aspects and if something is too
technical I'll just point it out and you
know maybe we can help each other out in
the comments or we can point you to
someone on slack who is more technical
who could maybe help get into the
nitty-gritty on those more technical
pieces
today's topic is what makes a good
LinkedIn profile and this is a really
interesting question because there's a
number of different ways to approach
your online presence and LinkedIn in
particular when you're thinking about
LinkedIn a lot of people resist wanting
to make one because they think you know
I have all these different profiles that
I have to create in order to do the job
search you know typically someone will
sit down and say alright it's time to do
the search what should I do and they'll
Google what should i do how do I start
my job search and they'll get
advertisements for every single job
posting website they'll get you know
everyone telling them that all they need
to do is three quick things and they'll
get that dream job no worries no fuss
right at the end of the day the truth of
the matter is what you do in order to
get the job really relies on how you
communicate and who you're communicating
to so when you think about your LinkedIn
what is the point of it what is the
point of a LinkedIn profile why do you
need to have it other than the fact that
everyone who's a career coach like me is
telling you to go create one well the
real value in LinkedIn is a number of
different things the first thing is it's
just a totally hyped up version of your
resume so we're constantly talking about
how you should try and get your resume
down to one page because at the end of
the day your resume is more of a
brochure something that's something will
someone will look at very quickly maybe
six seconds to 60 seconds and then put
to the side and continue a conversation
with you so if it's multiple pages if
you give them a booklet the chances of
them reading it similar to if you're
sitting in a doctor's office you pick up
a pamphlet the chances of you reading
all the things in that pamphlet are
fairly low you're going to skim you're
going to get an idea you're going to
move on but the difference between a
resume and your LinkedIn and your
LinkedIn started as an amped-up version
of your resume is that you can go into
far more detail you can list more
experience you can put more detail into
the description
of each one of those jobs I you if your
resume can only listen you know the most
recent five to ten years of things
you've done your Linkedin can go all the
way back to the beginning and cover
everything in your career if you would
like it to when you're filling out those
descriptions on LinkedIn you can start
very easily if you just if you don't
even have a LinkedIn just get it up and
running by copy and pasting your resume
over but what's really valuable is to
use that space that they give you
underneath the experience section and
underneath education and different
things like that to really expand on
these topics to really take the bullets
from your resume and give a little more
context a resume bullet you want it one
or two lines max but you can add quite a
bit more here and the nice thing about
it as you're adding this information in
is that it's improving your SEO ranking
now your SEO ranking that's search
engine optimization if you go to Google
and you type your name in what comes up
that's the question because you are
going to be googled before an interview
and so when someone sits down says
alright I've got an interview with this
person I've got to talk to them in an
hour I'm going to Google their name and
see what comes up your Linkedin should
come up your personal website should
come up your github whatever else it is
that you have up online your online
presence so that person can get a quick
snapshot of who you are what you've done
and what value you can bring into the
company so every time you add the
skillset you use to accomplish project
or talk about the skills you use to
create some sort of application those
the Google is going to read your
LinkedIn page and it's going to say
alright this person mentioned C++ a
bunch of times that means they must be
very good at C++ it's in your skills
section it's in the content of your
experience maybe it's even in your
header or in your summary and then you
move up in the search results and that's
the first thing I want to talk about
with LinkedIn LinkedIn is a place for
research as much as it is a place to
showcase
who you are so while on the one hand
it's a bit of a sales tool kind of like
a resume where someone will look you up
and be able to see a snapshot of your
work history on the other hand it's also
a research tool for them to find you and
you to find them the way that they find
you is they type in programmer Chicago
and all the programmers in Chicago come
up your name you want to get it as high
on that list as possible you don't wanna
be on page 7 if you're on page 7 you're
invisible if you're in the first 10 to
20 results you are much more visible
that's why you want to have a complete
profile now the other side of things is
that you get to use LinkedIn as a
research tool you get to look up
companies by their keywords you get to
look at content and see what is out
there what people are writing about you
get to look up people's profiles see
what work they've done see where they
work and reach out to make connections
so it goes both ways with the research
aspect and then the final piece of what
makes a great
what makes LinkedIn great and what makes
your Linkedin great is that you can also
use it as a way to share articles write
things and interact with people it is
after all a social network it's not just
about having it putting it up and
leaving it forever you want to be
engaged with it so if you are posting
videos posting articles sharing things
commenting on posts all those things are
going to increase not only your SEO but
also increase your visibility on the
platform the more you interact with it
the more prioritizes you and so what
ends up happening is if you're
commenting on a bunch of posts for
industry related job related topics
you're going to pop up into people's
feeds and just like a Nike billboard or
commercial or pop a bad right you're
going to pop up and the whole point of
that is visibility if no one knows you
exist when the problem arises it so
let's say I'm working on something and
I'm like oh I really need a junior
developer to come help me with this
project I'm gonna try and scan my brain
for who's a junior developer if no one
pops in my head I'm gonna go to LinkedIn
I'm going to type in junior developer
Chicago
you want to pop up in my head before I
even go do the search and if you're
popping up on my feet all the time as
the most active junior developer that is
in my network I'm not even gonna go to
the search bar I'm gonna reach out
directly to you but if let's say you
don't post as much you're not as as
active on the probe the profiles sorry
you're not as active on the website then
I go to the search bar and you want to
make sure that your profile is optimized
so you'll show up there so what ends up
making a great profile
the first thing completeness just make
sure all the sections are filled out you
can tweak it you can make it better over
time you can always add more as you go
but at the very basics make sure you
have a profile and that each one of the
sections is filled out the summary the
experience the education the volunteer
work if you have any and definitely the
skills section make sure all the skills
that you have all the technologies that
you use are listed in that skill section
so that you can show up in search
results number two the other thing that
makes a great great great LinkedIn
profile is an active LinkedIn profile
I'm on Twitter but I barely use it I
just populate Twitter through my
LinkedIn so every time I post on
LinkedIn it shows up on Twitter but if I
didn't set up that like it'll post there
as well I would be dead on Twitter no
one would interact with me and that's
the thing you want to be interacting
with people especially during the job
search so be sure to post be sure to
update your profile and be sure to
interact in the comments and things like
that if you don't know what to write
just interact with people that's that's
the basic level and it'll still you'll
share it what will happen if you comment
on people's posts is LinkedIn will share
your name and your comment with their
network and share their article with
your network so everyone goes up with it
and that's what's so great is when
people post things and share things they
are hoping people will engage with it no
one wants to post something and get zero
likes no one wants to post something and
get no comments
everyone wants comments so go comment on
the things that people
you look up to or people who do the job
that you wish you were doing are posting
because I'm gonna be like this person's
great I really want to interact with
them and I guarantee that this works
because I have personally interacted
with tons of you in the comments of my
own LinkedIn and the reason that you
have any clue who I am is because I post
those videos all the time a lot of you
have even gotten hours of free coaching
just because you commented in those
comments so it works go out and try it
and just watch LinkedIn will also give
you a little section that says how much
your activity is going up how many
people are viewing your profile and
that's that's really what we're trying
to get we're trying to get more eyeballs
on your work so that you can be seen and
get the job that you want so that's kind
of the intro a bit of a long tail
overview of why LinkedIn and how you can
use it and now we're going to jump into
your questions and go a little bit
deeper into what it is that is on your
mind today so please we've got some
great questions coming through but add
more to the chat we've got about 45
minutes left here to really dig in and
help you with your job search oh it's
alright that you're late thanks for
jumping on sorry just seeing some of the
comments coming through if you showed up
late make sure you comment with a
question alright our first question is
from Haiti or Hattie what is the best
way to write a short summary on LinkedIn
this is a really amazing question
because there's honestly a lot of
different ways to answer I've seen some
really amazing profiles that are really
out there and I've also seen some that
are very standard but work really well
so I'll tell you first
my favorite summary that I've seen in in
the past maybe year or two my favorite
summary that I've seen was someone who
works or I believe they currently work
in the self-driving car industry so they
wrote in their summary my goal is to
eliminate all human drivers from the
sounds kind of Terminator esque write it
but it's boys at caching and it's burned
in my brain forever and so I thought
that was one of the most interesting
profiles that I'd ever seen
summary sections that I had ever seen
because it said a lot about this person
it told me who they are
there's someone who's a little bit on
you know driven a little bit a little
bit pushes the edges pushes the
boundaries right they'll say something a
little a little out there on their
profile it also shows me what their goal
is and you know you can interpret that
by like oh my gosh all these
self-driving cars are gonna be taking
people out that's not what he means by
it of course what he means by it is that
his goal is the safety of the roads and
so he wants to eliminate human error
from our roads so by eliminating human
drivers you eliminate human error and
you focus on safety if every car was a
self-driving car that had perfect you
know those boundaries I'm not even sure
what all the technical stuff is called
but those boundaries around it they keep
them from bouncing into each other
bumpers invisible bumpers if every car
on the road had that there would be
almost no accidents right there would
still be accidents but compared to what
we currently have we're like you know
everyone driving home from the New
Year's Eve party is maybe it shouldn't
be on the road at that point in time
much much safer right I and you know one
of the most interesting I don't remember
the exact stat but I have heard that you
know one of the biggest benefits that
uber has come up with or one of the
biggest like outcomes or side effects of
the uber effect has been that like teen
drunk driving has decreased quite a bit
and accidents and fatalities and stuff
so this guy's on to something right and
and he puts it front and center in the
summary of his LinkedIn so anyone he's
having a conversation with about sensor
technology about cars about you know
self-driving technologies coding
everyone he's talking to the
conversation can always come back to
that main focus how do we eliminate
human drivers eliminate human error
and improve the safety of our roads so
if you have something like that if you
have a goal that is that big so for me
it's to help people get jobs it's also
to reduce stress and anxiety in people
so that's something that I showcase on
my LinkedIn profile if you have a big
you know long-term goal in your mind of
what you hope to accomplish with your
work this is the place to showcase it
the summary is about talking about the
future is really about being here's what
I hope to accomplish in the world now
you want to back that up by saying my
background is and it helps me do that so
for me with a background in marketing
and a background in coaching I'm able to
merge those skills in order to help
people get jobs and so I say the big
goal help people get jobs and reduce
stress and I do that by merging
marketing and career coaching in order
to help them get there and then you can
list any other skills and things that
you have there so let's say you're a
programmer and I you know you have a
background in linguistics like an
example we use on a different episode I
had someone they want to merge their
background in linguistics with
programming in order to create voice
software that helps make our lives more
efficient and by saying that in the
summary and then backing it up with here
are the technologies I use to accomplish
that and they just list off all the
different programming languages they
know it improves their SEO it's a quick
thing for me to see and understand and
if I work for any sort of company that
is involved in voice voice technology I
know this is the right person to talk to
so that's a great way to create a short
summary but at the very least just say
you know I'm looking to help it just at
the very least try and solve the problem
so if what you do is you create amazing
front-end designs for company websites
that allow them to increase engagement
then just say my goal is to increase
customer engagement through beautiful
front-end designs
you're saying what you create the value
you bring to a company and how you do it
and then you can even tack on who you do
it for if you know you know you want to
be in the fashion industry or you want
to be in the sports industry or
something along those lines if you're
that specific you can add that in but at
least at the very very least say the
problem that you're able to solve with
the work that you do alright our next
question is from Karthik Karthik our
next questions from Karthik how do I
find the right jobs and apply using
LinkedIn is it better or worse than just
using my resume LinkedIn at the end of
the day is better than your resume but
it won't replace your resume your resume
is always necessary because
unfortunately every single you know
application that you need to send in
needs to it typically is required that
you include a resume now I have been
seeing more and more that you can use
the apply with LinkedIn button and that
will replace your resume but then the
formatting will be weird it'll have a
lot of extra text different things like
that so if you do that option make sure
you go through and check the text so
that it looks good before you hit submit
so it's hard to save as better or worse
I personally think it's much much better
because it's more robust it goes into
more detail all the things that I've
already said on this call and and think
of the resume more as like a check mark
you're competent enough to create a
simple resume that I can review it's
it's one of the many tasks one of the
many check marks that you have to fill
out I don't think a resume will ever get
you the job but not having a good resume
could lose you the job it's kind of
weird like that your LinkedIn is sort of
like the backbone of how someone's gonna
find you online and see what you've done
so that's why you need that there how do
you find the right jobs I want to
address that one separately so how do
you find the right jobs you actually go
to LinkedIn and look at the search bar
and in the search bar on
then they give you three things that you
can search by the first one is jobs
that's what we typically all spend our
time on and you can filter jobs by
location experience industry and all
sorts of other things but everyone is
using that search feature that's kind of
what LinkedIn was built on what's more
interesting is going into people and
seeing who can I connect with that these
companies because if you don't have a
personal connection at these companies
it's an uphill battle to even get them
to look at your resume so what you want
to do is go to that people search also
go to those filters type in the job
title you're interested in the industry
you're interested in and your location
and it will give you a list of people
that you can interact with and network
with and reach out to that is a really
great way to do research in order to see
you know who out there is already doing
what you want to do and how to surround
yourself with those kinds of people but
also what companies are they working at
as you go down that list of a thousand
2,000 people you can take note of all
the companies that they're at and say
wow those companies didn't come up in my
job search but they will likely hire
another person for this role if they've
hired for this role before there's a
good chance they'll hire for this role
again so I'm going to keep an eye on I'm
going to put an alert on that one
because I'm really curious to learn more
and then a new thing that I'm testing
out is doing the content search so
that's the third option that you have in
LinkedIn search is to search by content
so literally if you click on the search
bar it brings up those three options
click on that and try and search by
keywords and what you can do with
keywords is you can type in your the
language you're most comfortable with in
coding right so you know Python hashtag
Python search under content maybe even
hash tag Python hash tag hiring and
it'll bring up anyone who is posted
about that recently so instead of going
around around through the job listing
and trying to get to the person you go
to the person first and then the job
listing so someone post a thing hey we
have a new role opening up for junior
devs who can do Python in the hash tag
- hashtag hiring that pops up you go
click on that you reach out to the
person who posted it or comment on there
either in the DMS or just comment
directly on the post apply to the job
and now you have a direct connection to
the job rather than a roundabout
connection through the job boards so
those are a few different ways that you
can use LinkedIn to really amp up your
search that are a little bit different a
little bit out of the box and not
everyone's doing everyone's going to the
job boards so try and circumvent it
through the people search and through
the content search if you can all right
Deepak how can I update my profile if
I'm going to change my career say from
Android to machine learning there's a
great question Deepak thank you so much
for asking it alright so you want your
profile to represent the job you want to
have so if a couple of things about your
profile people are searching for what
they need right now so I'm going to type
in developer Chicago in order to pull up
all the developers in Chicago if your
profile does not say you are a developer
in Chicago you are not going to show up
in that search and I will not be able to
reach out to you so what you need to do
is is update your profile so that when I
look at it and take a quick glance I can
see that you are right to reach out to
and talk to about this job so if your
header says seeking opportunities you're
not going to show up in my search
results because I'm not typing in
seeking opportunities Chicago so you
actually will miss out on those search
results and showing up in those search
results if your headline does not say
the job that you're looking to land so
you need to update your headline to
represent how you want to show up in the
search results now you got to make sure
that you have the skill set to actually
do that job or at least you're working
towards that skill set but if I'm
searching for in this case a mission
someone who works in machine learn
and you still have Android as your main
title it's going to be very hard for you
to come up in the search results then in
your summary you can say try um my
background in Android has prepared me to
do X Y & Z with machine learning and I
look forward to bringing this combined
experience to helping companies do X Y &
Z that will improve your SEO but also
once I get to your page explain to me
your career evolution and that career
evolution is very important I want to
know not only what you hope to do in the
future but where you're coming from so I
would just make those slight tweaks to
your profile so you can come up in the
search results and explain that growth
over time I was in Android I'm moving
into SH machine learning I'm doing my
Udacity course this is how I'm
accomplishing it and here's a value I
bring to companies so I hope that's
helpful thank you so much as a great
question we we need to not only look at
these as tools that hold a history of
our work but also tools that are selling
us for the future of our work or it and
that's the problem with LinkedIn it's
like walking that narrow line between
the past and the future we're like all
right I I don't want to be lying I don't
want to be making things up but I do
want to be pushing in a different
direction so I don't get pulled the
other way all right so give it a shot if
you have questions share it you know
with me on LinkedIn tag me something
like that make a post or just reach out
to me on slack and we can take a look
[Music]
all right brew shop I hope I pronounced
that right thank you for your question I
just started the android nanodegree do
you think I should add this to LinkedIn
I've not yet finished it if yes how do I
let recruiters know that I'm current
that I currently have a small amount of
knowledge awesome question and again
this is walking that tightrope between
explaining what you're working on and
what you hope to accomplish and what you
have experience in and have accomplished
and it's a tough line it's really it's
there's gonna be a lot of close calls
close calls of what you want to include
and don't want to include and maybe you
want to remove some old stuff and focus
on new stuff you know in this case in
particular as soon as you start anything
I see no reason not to add it if you
even if you just purchased it you know
you purchased it add it to your profile
because it will only help sequence you
in those search results now the chances
of you sequencing to the top of those
search results right after posting it is
not going to be super high it takes a
while for Google to crawl websites to
update and everything like that so I
wouldn't worry too too much about you
know over selling yourself when you're
putting a nano degree in your profile
when it comes to letting recruiters know
that you have a small amount of
knowledge allowed them to figure that
out that's their job is to vet you and
you're not you're not saying you know I
am you know the world's best Android
developer you're just saying I'm taking
a course and I think that's pretty
common knowledge to know that if you're
learning something if it's on and says
you know 2019 to present it's pretty
clear to me that you're you're new to
this right so I wouldn't worry too much
about trying to oversell yourself to
someone right that's their job to do
vetting and so you just need to clearly
state what your
working on how you're working on it what
you hope to accomplish and then when
you're in a real conversation with
someone explain the extent of your
knowledge and how you're continuing to
learn those are conversations that you
want to have in person if you try and
downplay yourself on social media you're
gonna end up really hurting yourself
because this is what ends up happening
I'm reading something and I don't think
anything negative about you I'm like oh
cool they've taken they're taking an
android nanodegree they're working on
their skills they're building their
projects they're doing some good stuff
maybe I want to reach out to them maybe
I don't that's up to me we'll figure it
out but then I read through your
description and your description says
beginner or recently started or you know
whatever these negative terms are these
are sort of self-deprecating there's
another word I want to use for this but
there's we always want to undersell
ourselves and it ends up hurting us
because we're putting ourselves down
we're kind of telling them not to look
at us when in truth they should look at
us and then make their own decision
don't disqualify yourself before someone
else does if you disqualify yourself for
a job before someone else tells you no
so you say well it seems too senior I'm
not gonna apply well that person
probably won't respond to me so I'm not
going to reach out well I don't know if
I'm ready yet to go to that networking
event if you keep doing that over and
over again you're never gonna get any
contacts because there's always some
reason not to do something there's
always something you don't know there's
always something you need to learn still
and so even with career coaching right
like I'm doing this every single day
helping as many people as possible but I
clearly don't know everything
people ask me quite detailed questions
about whiteboarding I've never done a
whiteboarding you know but I I can I can
give general advice there and then
explain my limitations and also explain
how I'm continuing to learn and that's
what you want to get to you want to get
to the point where you're having a real
conversation with someone rather than
trying to explain it in a pin like a
short one sentence thing on
LinkedIn so don't worry about it add it
to your profile and then when you get
into the conversation explain just
here's my experience here's what I'm
learning and here's how I hope to bring
value our next question
Murat what is the best way to market
oneself love this question I love the
fact that you're thinking about
marketing yourself in the job search it
is definitely a whole skill set in and
of itself and that's why I try to help
folks like you who you know have these
really amazing technical skill sets but
have not sat down and studied marketing
which fair you know that's not your job
it's not your job to learn how to craft
emails and do different things like that
but during the job search it is a very
useful skill to figure out how to
communicate effectively where to
communicate and all the things that go
along with it so the best way to market
yourself because you ask the question
what is the best way to market yourself
I'm gonna give you the very best way to
get out there and sell yourself and then
we can step it back to some other
options that might feel better for you
the very best way to market yourself
online is to create something that gives
you excuses to reach out to people now
what do I mean by that the reason I'm
even a career coach in the first place
is because I created a marketing podcast
and interviewed someone at the muse and
then they offered me a career coaching
job at the end of the interview if I
didn't ever have that podcast I never
would have had an excuse to reach out to
the editor at the muse and they never
would have had a hour and a half long
conversation with me that led to an
offer right so it's kind of crazy and I
did that podcast for almost two years
prior to that conversation happening so
I had no idea that that was going to
turn out the way it did but there were a
number of other opportunities that came
out of that
that one excuse to meet people the
podcast was every week I'm gonna reach
out to strangers I'm gonna talk to them
and I'm gonna learn about them and I'm
gonna find out cool and interesting
things and we'll see what happens but
just try and think about doing that
without the podcast right sure I think
try to think about reaching out to
someone and saying hey would you like to
have a two-and-a-half hour conversation
next Wednesday
it's like that's a pretty big meeting
that's a pretty tall order what are we
going to talk about um I don't know I
just kind of want to learn about you
right I think that that works when we
are networking when you're actively
trying to build your network and you say
hey I'm researching this industry and
I'd like to grab coffee and learn about
your job which is like a let's just say
a light version of a podcast right but
the podcast is what really opened up
those doors opened up those
conversations and the cool thing about
it was it was giving value and getting
value sharing their profile their
information with my network and then
they would go and share the podcast and
my information with their network and so
these are the kinds of things if you can
create an excuse to reach out that's
really gonna help you and I'll give you
some other examples I worked with
someone who really wanted to attend
Sports tech meetups in their town but
there were no sports tech meetups in
their town so we came up with a bright
idea to start one so they created a
meetup calm they got about like 35
people signed up to their meetup group
in the first week or two and just by
posting it on Meetup and then they had a
group of people a topic to discuss and
they said well shoot now I got to get a
speaker and host an event so they
reached out to the CEOs and the VPS and
the directors and all of their favorite
sports tech companies the excuse to
reach out I have an event I'm looking
for speakers you seem like a really
knowledgeable person would you like to
be the honorary speaker for my event
they got the I think VP of one of the
companies that they are really
interested in working for to show up
that person gave a talk I had a really
great conversation with the room and at
the end of the day without even asking
if
have any job openings the VP came up to
them and said this is a really wonderful
event do you happen to be in like the
market for a new job because we were
looking for some folks who are really
interested in tech and programming and
in sports he put himself in a position
so that he could have an excuse to reach
out conversations that were about the
industry and how he could be helpful and
then eventually that leads to wow this
is a valuable person bringing value into
my life I bet that they could bring even
more value if I brought them on
full-time these are the types of things
creating events creating a podcast
writing a blog and then interviewing
people via email or whatever comment but
even at a lower level commenting on
people's posts posting things on your
social media sites if you're not using
your Linkedin to share ideas you're not
using it fully so that's another way to
market yourself without having to create
a website and a podcast and a whole
brand and all this other stuff because
that's probably not your skill set just
utilize the profiles that are there
LinkedIn is there to give you visibility
that's why it exists so utilize the
visibility tools that it has so I would
say probably the easiest way to start is
just to pick your favorite 1 2 3 social
media accounts and interact with people
who work in the industry and do the job
that you want to be doing as much as
possible in between your job search and
other activities like networking and
stuff the best way to build your your
online brand in the market yourself is
to actually create it personal website
some sort of outreach mechanism and then
a history a trail of the conversations
whether it's a blog post or a podcast or
something like that that showcases your
growth over time you don't ever have to
be the expert you just have to be
curious excited and reaching out to
people so I hope that helps thank you so
much as a great question
all right I this name is in a different
language so I apologize I won't be able
to read it but we have a question here
that says I'm an electrical engineer and
have full-stack skills as well how do I
build a LinkedIn profile that can link
these two things together this is a
really good question I think the first
thing to realize is you know what was it
that interested you in electrical
engineering and then what also
interested you in full-stack programming
there was probably something about you
know the technical side of things the I
don't know maybe mathematical approach
you take to stuff whatever it might be
the way that you look at the world and
maybe even look at a few other hobbies
as well what is that thing that keeps
you engaged in these topics
do you enjoy building stuff you know
what is it and then take those skills
and start to think about well what is
the impact I'm hoping to have with these
whether it's with one specific company
one specific industry or you know the
world at large like that guy who wants
to eliminate drivers from all roads what
is it that you can build that solves
problems for other people if you can
figure out what problems you solve then
you can say well how do I solve those
problems
well I solve those problems by bringing
a you know a full-stack skill set and an
electrical engineering skill set to this
problem well what are the aspects of
that skill set that you bring to the
problem then you break it down even
further maybe take a personality test
sixteen personalities calm is a really
wonderful sight to just get some like
English language around your strengths
and your weaknesses so my very clean
easy to read easy to communicate stuff
it's not if you take you like a
myers-briggs test it tends to be very
jargony like yeah big words big industry
words but this one is a little bit
easier to digest and utilize so you can
start seeing what your strengths are you
can start seeing what your background
how the background
and then the way you build a LinkedIn
around it is you focus on the industry
or the problem that you want to solve
and you think about talking about that
so for me it's helping people get jobs
so typically everything I share I try to
relate back to people's careers so I
shared an infographic about you know all
these different aspects like education
is going up poverty is going down all
these great graphs and I tried to
connect it in some way to people being
more positive about their job search
right so if you can find things to share
that relate to the problem you want to
solve and then realize how the skills
you've developed from your background
contribute towards that goal I think
that's probably how you're going to be
able to bring those two things together
it's just two different perspectives
towards a similar approach to solving
problems if you have a chance before the
end of this chat to give us a little bit
more insight into the types of problems
you like to solve with full-stack
programming full stack development
please do and maybe we can go into a
little more detail there all right we've
got a question from awesome I don't have
any work experience before in front end
how do I build a good profile it's a
great question how do you build a
profile that showcases your experience
when you don't have any experience well
the first thing to do is as the previous
question stated showcase what you've
done in the past oh and here's a good
way to connect your past to your present
like my marketing skills are what showed
me how to build a good LinkedIn and then
eventually I use that or showed me how
to build good social media profiles and
then I eventually took that marketing
skill and now I'm using it here so it
the these things do build on each other
over time but if you don't have any
experience how do you build a good
profile the first thing to do is to just
fill in the experience you do have then
put in the education that you're getting
and maybe we list out the things that
you're learning and then create a new
space under experience or under
potentially volunteer depending on what
you're working on if you're volunteering
folks create this section that explores
what you're working on what you're going
to continue to learn because I would
assume if you don't have any experience
in the field right now you are trying as
hard as you can to gain that experience
whether it's building your own products
building your own projects reaching out
to organizations and trying to help them
through contract work part-time work
full-time work or reaching out to
volunteer organizations and trying to
support them to build what they need to
build so if you're a front-end developer
reach out to some front-end developer
organizations reach out to some about
now for profit companies nonprofit
organizations and see if you can help
them with their front and design for
free that way you can start putting it
into your experience and building out
your profile in the direction that you
want to go so the way that you actually
build out a great profile when you don't
have experience is to get that
experience but then also you can build
out your profile just by posting an act
and interacting online so going back to
what I said earlier go on to the youth
you know but LinkedIn allows you to post
articles so you can write about the
things you're learning and it allows you
to share posts so you can copy and paste
articles that you're reading and share
with the community so those are two
other ways that you can improve your
visibility around the topic and start
you know showing up in search results
for that topic even if you don't have
the actual experience just yet but don't
stop going out and trying to build that
experience
alright Shrikant thank you for your
question do I need to upload my resume
or video resume on LinkedIn after
completing my profile 100 percent it's a
really good question and this address is
something that I haven't fully touched
on about filling out your profile the
coolest thing that LinkedIn has done
recently as is allowed you to include
media under each one of your roles so
you have your you know you take your
experience section and it has every one
of your jobs you link the job to the
company profile so you get their nice
logo next to your name next to the
position you put in your job title you
put in your years and months worked you
fill out the little box that says you
know what did you do here's my bullets
and everything like that and then you
can attach media any presentations
you've done any URLs that you've built
any apps things like that so that's a
great place to showcase in additional
information so like a resume I look at
your resume and I read oh you built
these projects but I can't see the
projects on LinkedIn oh you built these
projects click I'm already at the
project boom right there do you need to
upload a resume or your video resume on
LinkedIn after completing your profile
well in your summary section you can
also include media if you go to my
LinkedIn page you can see I've included
a bunch of videos career tech videos
that I've been trying to keep up with
it's kind of hard but just trying to
keep it up there so that we can continue
to point people in the direction of the
things that we want them to see so I
would potentially include your resume
but that's probably better on a personal
website because it's sort of redundant
to have it on your LinkedIn a video
resume it's really cool that you have
one but again that might be better on
YouTube and then a link to the YouTube
page so I mean yeah I would say submit
you know include anything that you find
helpful it really doesn't hurt unless
it's like you know bad content or
something which very
so if you think it will be helpful
include it and the the worst setup
people will do is just not click on it
and that's okay but if you have if
you're using video if you're creating
video resumes I think that's awesome put
that on your YouTube channel and try and
develop your YouTube channel a little
bit that'll show up on Google search
results as well and it's very very very
good because not many people make
youtube videos I mean oh I know it's
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
you know young the younger you are the
more videos you probably make but in in
the tech space it's great to be building
video content and getting out there
alright we've got a
about ten minutes left so I'm going to
try and find some or while with so many
questions thank you all for sharing so
many questions this is awesome
I hope to make videos around these
questions it you know in and the time to
come but we'll try and get to as many as
you can here
d
you for asking if I will share my
LinkedIn profile you can just find me
Martin McGovern ma rtin MC govt er n
yeah feel free to connect with me happy
to connect with any of you and help out
any way I can
all right there's a lot of questions of
how to use LinkedIn so what I'm going to
try and do here is share my screen for
the last ten minutes and walk through a
bit of LinkedIn with you all let's see
if it allows me to share my screen well
there was an interesting little look all
right
so we're gonna go to LinkedIn go to the
main page here alright so when you get
to LinkedIn there's all these different
areas that you get to interact with if
you click here you go to your home page
so here's my home page I have LinkedIn
premium so of course you know I got this
little gold thing right here edit your
public profile URL this is what the Edit
Page looks like so I can change my name
here so see how this actually has my
full name on it everyone has a generic
URL to start but if you can put your
name your full name if you can go you
know grab that right now so no one else
steals it that's gonna be very important
for your SEO you're gonna want to update
your summary title here put your work
below these are all those posts and
activities that I'm talking about the
more posts you put they stay right here
your activities here and you can always
see more this is that big summary
section and you know I've put names of
brands that I've worked with that put
you know the my interest in education my
interest in career coaching and some of
my background so I'm a marketer an
educator a coach you can really just
list it out and then explain it let's
see what some of these questions are so
when you're doing this search and I want
to go back to that real quick this is
what
talking about with the search people
search job search content search content
search is something that's fairly new
and something I'm still learning but the
people that everyone knows the job
search but we can take a look at the
people search here people search allows
you to filter by all sorts of different
things always include all your
connections there's no reason to not
look at people there's no reason to
count people out until they say no or
until you can't find their connect their
email address this is how you filter by
your location I typically don't use
current companies because I don't like
people to get too hung up on any
individual company if you know you like
want to work at Amazon because of voice
search then look at industries and
here's what you do to find industries
that you can work at LinkedIn industry
codes we go here and you can see how all
the companies need to you know segment
themselves out by industry computer
games you know cosmetics if you're into
fashion entertainment fine art so on so
I'd go back here and let's just say I'm
really interested in marketing and
advertising okay
I actually know let's do a learning
because that's the industry I'm in
alright so I'm really interested in
eLearning and then down here you want to
type in the job title so let's just say
career coach we might not get that great
of results cuz I'm so specific right
here well we got 71 results so right
here here are all the people in Chicago
71 people in Chicago that are working in
the career coach section of the
e-learning industry and I can reach out
to these people and network and grow my
network surround myself with more people
doing what it is that I want to do so
let's do the same thing for you
clear those filters go back to all
filters alright so let's just say you
know we had someone in India we want to
say industry code automotive because
they're really interested in
self-driving cars and front-end
developer 180 a front-end developers
that work at these companies so that's a
company that hires front-end developers
that works in that industry contributor
and vision to autonomous driving
let's service dot in this is how you can
really get out there and build your
network so I really hope that today you
learned a few things about LinkedIn that
you can go and apply in your own life
that you can really take up here we go
let's stop the screen share all right I
really hope that you learned a few
things about LinkedIn that you can take
with you to make your profile better to
improve the way you search and use
LinkedIn as a research tool and then the
great thing about it is once you find
all these profiles that you can connect
with them before you connect I would try
and meet them and talk with them because
typically people will do one nice thing
for a stranger so if you say connect
with me and they connect the chances of
starting a conversation after that goes
down tremendously but if you send an
InMail and some of you asked about
premium why is premium good premium
allows you to reach out via in mail not
the most high success rate but better
than you know not having it so if you
have the finances I would potentially
recommend that and so what you can do is
you can reach out to those folks and
then if you once you've done that
research you can use a tool like find
that that email
sorry I thought I was still sharing my
screen for a second there but there's a
company there's a website called find
that dot email but also you can just
Google how to find someone's email and
reach out to those people in order to
start building relationships building
connections within these companies the
more you do that the better it'll be and
then when you actually apply for the job
you've got an inside person who could
pass your information along and that's
really the key here you want to have
your profile to just be good enough
remember your resume is just a check
mark of things that they need to make
sure you're competent your LinkedIn is a
repository for what you have done and a
glimpse into what you hope to do and
then even more than that it is a
research tool so just get your profile
to be good enough it doesn't have to be
perfect just try and get it as complete
as possible and then start networking
because that's where the real value is
going to be and if you use your profile
right you can go find a lot of people in
that people search and build toward that
career you really want to get to thank
you so much for watching I'm sorry we
didn't get to everyone's questions today
but we will have more career chats to
come and I'm super excited to help you
as you continue on your job search feel
free to connect with me on LinkedIn feel
free to send questions our way via slack
and the different alumni channels that
or group channels you might be part of
and just you know ping us and let us
know what other questions you have this
has been ask a career coach and I wish
you the very best in your job search
thank you again